Nous sommes au milieu des années 1970.
Michel Houellebecq est élève à l’Agro,
la grande école française de l'agronomie
(la science de l’agriculture).
Les élèves doivent faire un stage de presque
3 mois dans une ferme, puis remettre un rapport
de stage.
Celui de Houellebecq reçoit les éloges de
ses professeurs.
Il reçoit la lettre « A », la plus haute
dans l’échelle de notation.
L’examinateur admire son sens aigu de l’observation
et son expérience du terrain.
Le jeune Houellebecq ne s’attendait pas
à ça.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu’il est parti de la ferme au bout
de seulement deux jours !
Michel Houellebecq est l’écrivain français
contemporain le plus lu dans le monde.
Mais aujourd’hui, il n’est plus vraiment
un écrivain.
Il est une marque, une icône culturelle française.
Et pourtant, il est loin de faire l’unanimité.
Ses provocations lui ont aliéné une bonne
partie de l’opinion publique.
D’un côté, il donne l’impression d’être
comme les protagonistes de ses premiers romans,
une victime sincère de la société.
Mais certains — à commencer par son biographe
Denis Demonpion — estiment que Houellebecq
est un manipulateur super intelligent.
Vous allez voir qu’il y a un peu des deux.
Je vais vous raconter 10 anecdotes révélatrices
pour comprendre qui est vraiment Houellebecq.
Il y en a 3-4 qui sont surprenantes — et
aussi, il faut le dire, dérangeantes.
Nous sommes au milieu de l’année 1956.
Le petit Michel est né il y a seulement 5
mois.
Le contrat de travail de sa mère est fini.
Les parents de Michel en profitent pour faire
un voyage de 6 mois en Afrique.
Ils laissent leur bébé chez sa grand-mère
paternelle.
Houellebecq est donc un enfant quasi abandonné
par ses parents.
Il ressent un cruel manque affectif toute
sa vie
— et on peut également ressentir ce manque
affectif chez les protagonistes de ses romans.
Houellebecq entre donc dans la vie avec un
handicap affectif.
Au tout début, déjà, les parents abandonnent
leur nourrisson pour partir à l’aventure.
Moi qui ai eu la chance de recevoir beaucoup
d’attention et d’amour de mes deux parents,
cela me choque.
Je ne sais pas ce que vous en pensez — vous
pouvez me le dire dans les commentaires.
Et les parents de Houellebecq ne changent
pas à leur retour.
Ils se séparent rapidement.
Alors, le père, qui est un alpiniste chevronné,
voyage dans le monde entier.
La mère s’installe comme médecin généraliste
à la Réunion, et elle estime que sa quantité
de travail ne lui permet pas d’élever son
fils dans de bonne conditions.
Le petit Michel grandit donc sans ses parents.
Et ça, ça explique en partie sa critique
— notamment dans Les Particules élémentaires
— de la contre-culture libertaire des années
60 dans laquelle ont baigné ses deux parents.
Ils sont tous les deux intelligents, cultivés,
et épris de liberté.
Mais ils aiment tellement la liberté qu’ils
y sacrifient leurs responsabilités.
Et ce sont les autres qui en font les frais.
À commencer par leur fils.
La mère de Houellebecq abandonnera également
son second enfant.
Le père de Michel s’appelle « René Thomas
».
Sa mère s’appelle « Janine Ceccaldi ».
Donc l’écrivain s’appelle officiellement
« Michel Thomas ».
Alors où est-ce qu’il a trouvé le nom
« Houellebecq » ?
Et POURQUOI avoir choisi ce nom ?
Eh bien c’est le nom de jeune fille de sa
grand-mère paternelle, celle qui s’est
occupé de lui quand ses parents l’ont abandonné
à 5 mois.
« Henriette Houellebecq » est la personne
qui a le plus compté dans sa vie
— c’est pour ça qu’il a choisi ce nom.
C’est elle qui lui a donné sa dose d’amour
originelle.
Elle ne s’est pas contentée de garder son
petit-fils.
Elle l’a choyé et gâté, sans réserve.
Et chez les humains comme chez les animaux,
l’adulte reste profondément attaché au
protecteur dont il a reçu des soins quand
il était enfant.
Lui qui est si sarcastique, Houellebecq n’a
jamais émis la moindre critique envers sa
grand-mère paternelle.
Il a également reçu de l’amour de ses
autres grands-parents, ses grands-parents
maternels, chez lequels ses parents l’ont
laissé après leur séparation.
Nous sommes en 1975 : Houellebecq a 19 ans.
Après 2 ans en classe préparatoire « bio
» au lycée Chaptal à Paris, il a passé
les écrits des concours des grandes écoles
les plus réputées.
Résultat ?
Il est admissible partout, y compris à la
très prestigieuse École normale supérieure.
Il finit même 9ème des écrits du concours
de Normal Sup !
Mais il y a un truc qui le dérange : aucun
de ses copains n’y est admissible.
Il n’a pas envie de perdre ses amis de prépa,
donc il « sêche » l’oral de Normal Sup.
Cette anecdote révèle que Houellebecq est
un surdoué sans ambition.
Enfin, jusqu’à ce qu’il trouve sa voie.
Son aisance intellectuelle, c’est d’abord
une affaire de gènes.
Le père de Houellebecq a quitté l’école
à 13 ans, mais il a une vive intelligence
qui lui vaut le respect de ses amis.
La mère de Houellebecq est clairement une
surdouée.
En plus de son militantisme communiste — ce
qui lui donne une bonne culture politique
—
en plus de son engagement, elle fait médecine,
et elle termine major de promo.
Elle a également une grande culture littéraire.
Elle est capable de réciter par cœur des
passages entiers de Dostoïevski.
Pas étonnant, avec de tels parents, que Houellebecq
soit doué.
Mais c’est l’attention de ses grands-parents
maternels qui permet de développer son potentiel.
Sa précocité les éblouit : à 3 ans, il
sait lire ;
et à 4 ans, il écrit des mots compliqués
sans faire aucune faute.
À l’école, au collège, au lycée, en
prépa, il aura moins d’efforts à fournir
que les autres.
« Un surdoué mental, un sous-doué affectif
», dit sa mère.
Avec sa voix grave sculptée par le tabac,
Philippe Séguin a été le plus charismatique
président de l'Assemblée nationale (où
siègent les députés de la République française).
Il exerce cette fonction de 1993 à 1997.
Un jour, Philippe Séguin a un problème avec
son ordinateur.
Il contacte donc le service d’assistance
bureautique de l’Assemblée.
Il a affaire à un homme bizarre, lent, qui
semble être dans un autre monde.
Comme le président de l’Assemblée a du
mal à faire confiance à ce dépanneur, il
insiste, il le secoue verbalement.
Ce dépanneur n’est donc pas fan de Séguin,
qu’il appelle « le gros très chiant ».
Vous l’avez compris, le dépanneur, c’est
Michel Houellebecq.
Au début des années 1990, il travaille au
service informatique de l’Assemblée nationale.
Dans les années 1980, il avait travaillé
dans une société de services en informatique,
avant d’être contractuel pour le ministère
de l’Agriculture.
Cette anecdote révèle que Houellebecq a
l’expérience du monde du travail moderne.
Contrairement à beaucoup d’auteurs et d’artistes,
qui critiquent la société depuis l’extérieur,
Houellebecq, lui, a eu un quotidien professionnel
qui ressemble à celui de beaucoup de gens
(la France étant une économie de services).
Pour le dire simplement, il a été « un
Français moyen » sur le plan professionnel.
Dans la vingtaine et la trentaine, il occupe
des emplois purement alimentaires.
Comme beaucoup de Français, son travail ne
l’intéresse pas, mais il n’a pas le choix.
Ses finances sont fragiles et il a un enfant
à charge.
Et contrairement à ce que sa bizarrerie laisse
imaginer, il est un employé fiable.
Il est à l’heure ; il ne crée pas de problèmes
; il fait ce qu’on lui demande, et même
de manière intelligente.
Il est intégré et apprécié là où il
travaille.
Surtout, il observe en agronome le milieu
où il évolue.
Son expérience du monde du travail lui permettra
de retranscrire l’ambiance bureaucratique
déprimante qui est celle de beaucoup de grandes
entreprises et d’administrations.
Au début des années 1990, toutes les maisons
d’édition refusent Extension du domaine
de la lutte, le premier roman de Houellebecq.
Or, beaucoup de gens — moi compris — pensent
aujourd’hui que c’est le meilleur.
Enfin, c’est facile après coup d’accuser
les éditeurs de ne pas avoir eu de flair.
À l’époque, Houellebecq bénéficie pourtant
du soutien de Dominique Noguez, un critique
littéraire qui a ses entrées dans le monde
de l’édition.
C’est lui qui pousse pour faire publier
Extension du domaine de la lutte — en vain.
Mais Houellebecq bénéficie d’un soutien
encore plus puissant : celui de la femme qui
l’aime.
Et cette femme a une position encore plus
utile que celle du critique littéraire Dominique
Noguez :
elle est la secrétaire de la maison d'édition
La Différence, qui a publié le premier recueil
de poésie de Houellebecq.
Autrement dit, elle est une insider dans le
milieu de l’édition.
Elle HARCÈLE littéralement Maurice Nadeau,
le patron des éditions du même nom.
Et un jour, il accepte de publier Extension
du domaine de la lutte.
Cette anecdote montre que Houellebecq n’est
pas un génie sorti de nulle part.
À la sortie de son premier roman, il est
déjà un initié du monde littéraire parisien.
Il est entré dans ce microcosme par la poésie.
Dès ses études d’agronomie, il participe
à des soirées où se retrouvent des amoureux
de poésie, ce genre mal-aimé.
Une fois dans la vie active, il continue.
De relation en relation, il se rapproche des
éditeurs de poésie.
Il publie d’abord ses poèmes dans des revues.
Puis un recueil, La Poursuite du bonheur,
paraît en 1991.
On ne publie pas un recueil de poèmes pour
gagner de l’argent
— et pourtant, la maison d’édition doit
rapidement réimprimer un nouveau stock d’exemplaires
: les ventes ont dépassé ses espérances.
Houellebecq obtient même en 1992 le prix
Tristan Tzara,
du nom du poète du début du XXe siècle
qui a fondé le dadaïsme.
Ce premier succès lui permet de pénétrer
un peu plus le microcosme littéraire parisien.
Il se rapproche par exemple de Jean-Edern
Hallier, le polémiste le plus en vue des
années Mitterrand.
Le talent de Houellebecq est de plus en plus
reconnu.
Jusqu’au succès inattendu d’Extension
du domaine de la lutte.
Pardon pour l’interruption, mais j’ai
une question à vous poser :
Vous croyez VRAIMENT que les gens ont lu tous
les livres dont ils parlent ?
Bien sûr que non — sinon on ne pourrait
pas parler de grand-chose.
Eh oui, il y a vingt-quatre heures dans une
journée, et il faut travailler, manger, dormir,
et sortir le chien.
Donc le secret de la culture générale, ce
n’est PAS de lire des livres.
C’est quoi alors ?
Eh bien en fait, il n’y a pas qu’un seul
secret, il y en a CINQ.
Les étudiants et les personnes les plus cultivés,
les profs, et les intellectuels CONNAISSENT
ces cinq secrets, mais ils se gardent bien
d’en parler…
Les gens qui les découvrent réussissent
à développer RAPIDEMENT et FACILEMENT leur
culture générale, parce que leur rapport
au savoir A CHANGÉ.
Et une fois qu’ils APPLIQUENT les cinq secrets,
ils comprennent toutes les références des
personnes cultivées ;
ils savent s’exprimer avec profondeur sur
n’importe quel sujet ;
ils brillent par leur culture dans les conversations
et dans les débats ;
et ils ont le recul nécessaire pour faire
preuve d’esprit critique.
Ça vous intéresse ?
Eh bien je vous révèle les cinq secrets,
et je vous explique comment les appliquer
DÈS AUJOURD’HUI
pour vous cultiver DIX FOIS PLUS RAPIDEMENT
SANS VOUS PRENDRE LA TÊTE.
Pour recevoir les cinq secrets, inscrivez-vous
simplement soit en cliquant sur le lien qui
apparaît maintenant en haut à droite de
la vidéo, soit en cliquant sur celui qui
est dans la description de la vidéo.
C’est l’histoire de 10 secondes, donc
faites-le maintenant,
et vous pourrez découvrir le premier secret,
qui vous attendra bien au chaud dans votre
boîte mail après avoir regardé cette vidéo.
Voilà voilà, je vous ai dit ce que je voulais
vous dire.
Bonne vidéo !
Nous sommes à l’été 1998.
Le directeur du camping L’Espace du Possible
appelle Flammarion.
Il est fou de rage : le 2ème roman de Houellebecq,
Les Particules élémentaires, qui s’apprête
à sortir, donne une très mauvaise image
de son établissement :
il passe pour un repaire de babas cool frustrés
sexuels.
Houellebecq refuse de changer le nom du camping.
Le directeur saisit donc la justice avec une
procédure d’urgence. Il obtient la destruction
de tous les exemplaires disponibles.
Pour éviter cela, Flammarion doit modifier
le nom du camping, et il faut le faire place
pour place.
Houellebecq a une seule nuit pour trouver
un nouveau nom qui comporte autant de caractères
que L’Espace du Possible :
ce sera « Le Lieu du Changement ».
Il y a ensuite une audience.
Les grands noms du monde littéraire parisien
se succèdent pour demander le rejet des poursuites
au nom de la liberté du romancier.
Seulement, la liberté du romancier, Houellebecq
la pousse très très loin…
Cette anecdote illustre un de ses travers
: il ne respecte pas, dans ces romans, l’anonymat
des personnes dont il s’inspire.
Non seulement il raconte des scènes réelles
d’une manière peu flatteuse pour les personnes
impliquées, mais en plus il donne leurs véritables
noms !
C’est du jamais vu dans la fiction.
Par exemple, dans Extension du domaine de
la lutte, son premier roman, il reproduit
très précisément la nomenclature du ministère
de l’Agriculture avec ses directions, ses
départements, ses bureaux, ses sous-directions.
Et puis il MET EN SCÈNE d’anciens collègues.
Plus précisément ceux qu’il n’appréciait
pas. Il en fait des portraits féroces, sans
changer leur identité.
Parmi les victimes qui ont été mises au
courant, certaines ont hésité à porter
plainte.
Mais elles ont finalement renoncé, anticipant
que cela nuirait encore plus à leur anonymat.
Je vous lis un passage des Particules élémentaires.
C’est à propos d’un personnage qui veut
se reconvertir dans le rock à l’âge de
26 ans.
« Avant de faire le tour des studios d’enregistrement,
il décida d’enlever deux ans à son âge.
C’était très facile à faire : il suffisait,
au moment où on lui demandait son âge, de
répondre : "Vingt-quatre ans." Naturellement,
personne ne vérifiait. »
Si si, il y a des personnes qui vérifient.
Un biographe rigoureux comme Denis Demonpion,
par exemple.
Il a trouvé que Houellebecq est né en 1956
(ce qui est confirmé par les actes d’état
civil),
et non en 1958, comme l’écrivain l’a
maintes fois affirmé.
Et Houellebecq ne se rajeunit pas uniquement
dans les conversations.
En 2002, ses propos controversés sur l’islam
lui valent un procès.
Le mémoire remis aux juges par l’avocat
stipule dès les premières lignes que Houellebecq
est né en 1958
— alors que, dans des documents antérieurs
à sa célébrité, il dit lui-même qu’il
est né en 1956.
Pourquoi aller jusque là ? Pourquoi mentir
sur un détail ?
D’un côté, dans ses romans — c’est-à-dire
dans la fiction — il met en scène, sous
leurs vrais noms, de vraies personnes qui
n’ont rien demandé ;
de l’autre côté, dans la réalité, dans
des documents à valeur juridique, il change
son année de naissance.
Et puis certaines personnes qui le fréquentent
le soupçonnent de raconter des histoires
inventées.
En fait, comme beaucoup de romanciers, Houellebecq
prend plaisir à brouiller les pistes entre
la réalité et la fiction. À mystifier le
public.
Mais Céline ne disait-il pas : « Une biographie,
ça s’invente » ?
Nous sommes le mardi 11 septembre 2001.
Michel Déon, un écrivain français, a accueilli
Houellebecq après une violence dispute conjugale.
L’après-midi, les deux hommes discutent
tranquillement autour d’un verre.
Pendant ce temps, l’épouse de Michel Déon
fait les courses au village.
Et à l’épicerie, elle remarque un attroupement
inhabituel devant le téléviseur.
Les images incroyables d’avions de ligne
fonçant sur les tours du World Trade Center
tournent en boucle.
De retour chez elle, elle dit à son mari
qu’il faut absolument allumer la télévision.
Houellebecq et ses hôtes restent bouche bée
devant l’écran.
À un moment, Michel Déon lui dit : « Vous
êtes sauvé ».
Pourquoi est-ce qu’il lui dit ça ?
Parce que Houellebecq s’est mis à dos une
partie de l’opinion publique en critiquant
— et on peut même plutôt dire EN INSULTANT
l’islam.
La provocation qui lui a causé le plus de
soucis, c’est lorsqu’il a dit en 2001
dans une interview du magazine Lire :
« La religion la plus con, c’est quand
même l’islam ».
Cependant, la phrase n’a pas que des effets
négatifs.
Comme le scandale atteint des sommets, les
ventes s’envolent.
Plateforme, le 3ème roman de Houellebecq,
se vend à 200 000 exemplaires EN 12 JOURS.
200 000 exemplaires en 12 jours !
Ce que révèle cette anecdote, c’est que
la controverse y est pour beaucoup dans le
succès de Houellebecq.
La formule est simple : les propos qui heurtent
la morale sociale captent l’attention ;
comme les médias vivent de l’attention
du public, ils relaient les propos controversés
tenus dans le cadre de la sortie du livre
;
Houellebecq bénéficie donc d’une ÉNORME
publicité.
Et comme les gens s’attendent à découvrir
d’autres propos controversés dans le roman,
ils l’achètent.
Et il y en a : Houellebecq parle crûment
de sexe ; dénigre les femmes, et l’islam.
Bien sûr, on ne peut pas résumer ses romans
à cela.
Mais se seraient-ils aussi bien vendus sans
parfum de scandale ?
Fin 2022, un vidéaste néerlandais propose
à Houellebecq de filmer ses ébats à trois
— lui, sa femme, et une jeune Hollandaise,
prétendument étudiante en philo et fan de
sa plume.
Houellebecq accepte.
Il y a deux tournages, l’un à Paris, l’autre
à Amsterdam.
Mais voilà, lors de la diffusion de la bande
annonce début 2023, Houellebecq s’oppose
finalement à la sortie du film.
Ce n’est pas ce qui était prévu. Il aurait
été négligeant en signant le contrat.
Mais bien sûr, l’histoire est relayée
par tous les médias.
Houellebecq revient sur le devant de la scène.
Il se justifie dans un récit-confession qui
sort en mai 2023, Quelques mois dans ma vie.
Cette anecdote illustre le fait que la sexualité
est un ingrédient essentiel de l’identité
artistique de Houellebecq.
Dans ses livres comme dans sa vie personnelle.
Certes, ce n’est plus un tabou comme ça
l’était il y a un siècle.
Mais la sexualité est toujours — avec la
violence — le signal le plus puissant pour
capter l’attention de l’être humain.
À un niveau superficiel, Houellebecq parle
beaucoup de sexe dans ses romans.
Il décrit les désirs des personnages ainsi
que leurs ébats en termes crus.
Il évoque l’échangisme, qu’il pratique
lui-même.
Mais ses romans transmettent également un
message profond.
Ils ont un thème majeur qui font de Houellebecq
le sociologue de l’époque : la misère
sexuelle occidentale.
Il révèle une prétendue vérité dérangeante
: les hommes souffrent d’avoir une vie sexuelle
très limitée, si ce n’est inexistante.
À cet égard, il est un peu un précurseur
du mouvement Red Pill
— en référence à la célèbre scène
du film Matrix —
mouvement selon lequel la société occidentale
contemporaine est responsable de la misère
sexuelle des hommes.
Nous sommes à la toute fin de l’année
2010.
Bruno Le Maire, le ministre de l’Agriculture,
contacte l’ambassade de France en Irlande.
Il demande qu’on réduise les obligations
sanitaires pour rapatrier la dépouille d’un
chien en France.
Un avion est spécialement affrété pour
l’animal.
Aux frais de la République, et donc du contribuable.
Ce chien, c’est Clément, le fidèle compagnon
de Houellebecq.
Et il est bien plus qu’un chien pour lui
:
les proches de l’écrivain disent que Clément
était sa seule famille.
Son seul point fixe dans l’existence.
Houellebecq est toujours avec Clément. Il
dort même avec le quadrupède.
Quand il est menacé après ses propos sur
l’islam, il confie Clément à des personnes
de confiance afin que l’animal soit en sécurité.
Cette anecdote révèle la misanthropie de
Houellebecq.
Comme Schopenhauer, qui l’a influencé et
qui avait également un chien auquel il tenait
beaucoup
— comme Schopenhauer, Houellebecq a une
vision sombre de l’humanité.
Il trouvait chez Clément ce qu’il ne trouvait
pas chez ses semblables : la pureté et la
fidélité dans l’affection.
Des années après le décès de l’animal,
le Palais de Tokyo, le musée le plus branché
de Paris, permet à Houellebecq de créer
sa propre exposition pour 2 mois.
Il fait de Clément la mascotte du programme
des expositions.
Il lui consacre une enfilade de salles, baptisée
« Amour absolu ».
Les spectateurs peuvent y découvrir un diaporama
de l’animal, une statue, ainsi que tous
ses jouets et peluches dans des vitrines.
Si vous aimez l’esprit de cette vidéo — à
savoir découvrir des choses intéressantes
en allant à l’essentiel et sans se prendre
la tête — alors vous aimerez probablement
mon programme Culture Express.
C’est un programme méthodique pour devenir
facilement une personne cultivée en seulement
quelques mois.
Il couvre tous les domaines de la culture
générale : vous maîtriserez les connaissances
essentielles sur l’histoire de l’humanité,
sur l’histoire de France, en économie,
en science politique, en psychologie, en science,
en littérature, en art, en religion, et en
philosophie.
Vous ne serez plus jamais à court de choses
à dire et vous gagnerez la confiance nécessaire
pour briller en toutes circonstances.
Vous pouvez en savoir plus en cliquant sur
le lien qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
ou bien sur celui qui est dans la description,
ou bien encore en tapant directement l’adresse
qui s’affiche à l’écran dans la barre
de recherche.
Mais je pense que la meilleure façon de vous
donner une idée du programme est d’écouter
ce que les membres ont à en dire.
Valentine, qui reconnaît l’énorme quantité
de travail que ce programme a représenté
pour moi, dit que « c’est une véritable
mine d’or [...] L’essentiel est là, tout
est simple, pratique, très bien expliqué,
concentré, il n’y a plus qu’à recopier
et à apprendre. Ce travail est vraiment formidable
et passionnant. »
Maxence m’écrit directement dans les commentaires
en-dessous d’une vidéo du programme : « Ta
formation est vraiment remarquable. J'étais
un peu dubitatif étant donné le prix initial
mais je ne regrette pas, c'est un vrai travail
de synthèse que tu nous proposes et le format
vidéo est très adapté pour moi qui ai une
mémoire essentiellement auditive. Le choix
des thèmes et des chapitres est pertinent
et je trouve que tu as trouvé la dose d'approfondissement
parfaite ; à la fois précis mais sans fioritures
! »
Vincent, lui, fait carrément ma pub : « J’ai
d’ailleurs recommandé votre formation à
ma sœur qui travaille comme diplomate [...]. La
semaine dernière, elle a déjà eu l’occasion
de mettre à profit, dans ses discussions,
les connaissances que vous avez diffusées.
»
Vous verrez d’autres témoignages comme
ceux-ci dans les commentaires si vous rejoignez
le programme. Et si vous vous inscrivez, vous
bénéficiez d'une garantie résultats : une
fois que vous aurez terminé le programme,
je vous rembourserai intégralement si vous
estimez que vous n’avez pas acquis une solide
culture générale.
Si vous voulez en savoir plus, cliquez sur
le lien qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
ou bien sur celui qui est dans la description,
ou bien encore tapez directement l’adresse
qui s’affiche à l’écran dans la barre
de recherche.
Plus de 800 membres ont déjà tiré parti
de ce programme, et je serais ravi qu’il
en soit de même pour vous.
Dans tous les cas, j’espère que cette vidéo
vous a plu.
Je suis Romain, et vous, vous étiez sur 1000
idées de culture générale.
Rappelez-vous que vous n’avez pas besoin
de vous prendre la tête pour vous intéresser
au meilleur de la pensée.